la bicyclette pour cyclistes fatigué
préférant la position allongée est
instantanément transformable en
aéroplane
voici encore un sensationnel
hélicoptères individuel systématiquement
refusées par air france quelques
manoeuvres très simple quelques groupies
sans mystère mettant à la disposition de
l'homme du 20e siècle
l'engin ont dû commencer à ressentir
cruellement le besoin
l'hélicoptère individuel construits en
amérique a été présenté sur l'héliport
parisien d'issy les moulineaux
douze kilomètres à l'heure et la
possibilité de monter à 4 mm on mesure
le progrès sur l'anti de bicyclettes de
nos pauvres au pape
enfin d'amérique m'bia l'image dont tous
les hommes ont rêvé depuis ici car
l'homme volant du moins le solde à
volants puisque c'est l'armée américaine
qui a expérimenté la nouvelle ceinture
fusée avec succès comme ouvre